hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the fede world blitz
championship it's a game from round 16
Magnus Carlsen still in the lead faces
Daniel do both he's not in the so lead
and Nakamura and Vladimir Kramnik caught
up to him so here anything can happen so
anyone can now grab the sole lead and
the Kramnik face is Nakamura
so here across and face is unofficial
second and it's very interesting to see
how well either of them try to try to
surprise the other one without further
ado let's check it out Magnus with the
white pieces opens with c4 the English
is on the border we have Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and the c5 we have g3 e 6
by 2 above Knight to f3 and d5 now this
is the lion dubov always plays against
English he played against everyone see
caps our Sun d5 with ecaps or Sundy 5
and now d4 Knight to c6 do both played
this against a couple of times against
Nakamura he played against mom in Europe
although I don't think he ever will not
ever but against the d top elite players
I don't think he ever got a win in this
line Busch of g2 by Magnus with C
captures on d4 Knight captures and now
Bishop to c5 attacking the knight Knight
back to b3 attacking the bishop and
Bishop to b6 Magnus castles here and now
d4 attacking the knight 9a for going
after the bishop and here you cannot go
Bishop c7 because the white can just
pick up the knight on c6 and then win
the d4 pawn so not something you want to
do so du Bois just castles here and the
Magnus continuous development Bishop g5
we have rook to e8 and here there is a
game Du Bois played against Nakamura
where Nakamura captured on b6 in this
position the game ended in a draw but
Magnus goes for rook to e1 and it is a
new move in the positions already as of
move 13 so we h6 by dubov and now Magnus
takes takes a few moments to calculate
and decide that he indeed indeed is
interested in the d4 pawn so character
sin b6
we have a capture son b6 captures and f6
we have sorry captures and C
first eliminating the defender of the d4
pawn we have B captures and c6 and now
even captures on f6 Queen captures and
now he just eliminates the pawn so he
grabs a pawn and he offers a queen trade
dubov says okay we can trade Queens but
I'm not interested in developing your
knight even further so Queen back to the
8th now he wants his rook on the D file
Magnus just goes back Queen c3 with an
attack on the pawn here c5 by dubov
which is what you would expect you
expect he wants to put his bishop on
this beautiful diagonal and having a
bishop on this diagonal is compensation
enough for the sacrificed pawn we have
rook a to d1 magnus uses this
opportunity to get away from the defense
of the a point as this move comes with
an attack on the Queen Queen to e7 and
now Knight the c1 the pawn is now
defendant the point is coming to a3 but
Magnus wants to remain over the Knights
oh yeah you know just as well
h5 by dubov as he will put the bishop on
this diagonal he also wants to bust open
the position which with h4nh captures an
g3a3 by magnus now the knight can be
activated and now h4 we have Knight 2 D
3 sorry about that
oh sorry about that had something
dropped over so tonight's the d3 getting
the right back into the game and then
now rook the a4 here do of Christ a nice
rough lift he wants to bring the rook
over to the attack and while Magnus
could go Queen to b3 with a double
attack to attack the rook ended the b6
pawn here it's unlikely that Du Bois
would go for the passive rook a6 he
would probably go for Queen to e4
centralizing the Queen and then well do
you really want to grab another pawn
against a guy like dubov who is coming
after you very unlikely so instead after
this rook to a4 move Magnus goes for
Knight to f4 the knight on f4 will be an
extremely useful piece preventing the
rook from joining the attack and also it
protects the e2 pawn for for future
purposes we have Bush up the b7 finally
the bishop comes to this long diagonal
and now rook to d3 by Magnus very
important as now if pawn captures
perhaps the rook will be able to capture
not right away since the knight would be
hanging but in some scenarios we've
worked he for now putting even more
pressure on the e-file and now f3
attacking the rook and here is the
crucial moment of the game
the point is Magnus is up a pawn he
really consolidated here and wherever
you move the rook rook e5 rook before
doesn't matter if you move the rook
efore is coming and now after the ropes
are traded well the the pawn structure
here really prevents the bishop from
being useful and now Magnus will just
enjoy his extra pawn so not really
anything to to look forward to with
black so instead after this F to remove
duo of Christ H captures and g3 as
Magnus was really low on time I believed
what was around a minute and a half a
Magnus for some 20 seconds on the clock
so he tried this H captors and g3
checking to see if Magnus would react to
this but Magnus is not afraid no you
know or wishes to be to be bluffed upon
so just F captures rook on e4 asking
what do you want to do here do both
plays G captures an h2 with check and
the Magnus captures you do not want to
go to h1 because this allows Queen to e4
with check and then well the Queen can
just continue harassing the white Kings
Magnus captures it and now Queen to h4
with check with night age reblocking
only move because you're gonna lose the
night so nice to h3 and now rook
captures on e4
but now Magnus goes for rook to g3 it
threatens mate since Queen g7 would be
made and it's the good decision if you
go rook g1 it
well rook captures I need to just lose
this since the bishop slices over this
way and you will have to block give up
the rook and then you're getting made it
so after rook captures any form we have
rook to g3 threatening mate now and here
do both blocks it with f6 but now feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the quickest way to victory for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
to move maneuver and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show its
Queen to b3 check point is well you have
to move the king where are you going to
move the king that doesn't really matter
where you move the king well if you go
somewhere like King to FA then Queen
captures and b6 is very strong so do
both play the King to h7 but now Magnus
just went Queen to f7 it's basically the
same idea mate is threatened and the
bishop is threatened so here dubov tried
his last trick which is the rook to g4
now if of course if Queen captures then
you can capture the rook and g3 but
Magnus is not interested in such tricks
he just captures and g4 we have Queen
captures and now Queen captures on b7
and it was in this position unmoved 33
that Daniel dubov resigned the game and
a very important victory for Magnus
Carlsen in his attempt to win the triple
World Chess Championship since he
already is the classical world champion
he is now the world rapid champion as
well and he's trying to claim that a
world blitz championship title and the
game between Nakamura and and the
Kramnik ended in a draw not Kramnik
completely outplayed Nakamura and then
Nakamura with three seconds on the clock
was able to hold
Kramnik to a draw or being a piece down
which is just insane that and Nakamura
really is a I believe it is the
strongest blitz player in the world well
okay Magnus should be the strongest in
everything but what
Kimora does in blitz that's that's
really insane but yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank you equate ran a gladkov chunk of
Joseph amatzia
now how many mizuchi and Tasos are on
parties for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
blitz championship were intelligence so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day